good morning everyone and thank you for
being here two years ago the acting
Attorney General asked me to serve as
special counsel and he created two
special counsels office the appointment
order directed the office to investigate
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election
this included investigating any links or
coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign now I have not
spoken publicly during our investigation
I'm speaking out today because our
investigation is complete the Attorney
General has made the report on our
investigation largely public we are
formally closing the special counsel's
office and as well I'm resigning from
the Department of Justice to return to
private life I'll make a few remarks
about the results of our work but beyond
these few remarks it is important that
the offices written work speak for
itself
let me begin where the appointment order
begins and that is interference in the
2016 presidential election as alleged by
the grand jury in an indictment Russian
intelligence officers who are part of
the Russian military launched a
concerted attack on our political system
the indictment alleges that they used
sophisticated cyber techniques to hack
into computers and networks used by the
Clinton campaign they stole private
information and then release that
information through fake online and
identities and through the organization
WikiLeaks the releases were designed and
timed to interfere with our election and
to damage a presidential candidate and
at the same time as the grand jury
alleged in a separate indictment a
private Russian entity engaged in a
social media operation where Russian
citizens posed as Americans
in order to influence an election these
indictments contain a legate allegations
and we are not commenting on the guilt
or the innocence of any specific
defendant every defendant is presumed
innocent unless and until proven guilty
the indictments allege and the other
activities in our report to describe
efforts to interfere in our political
system they needed to be investigated
and understood and that is among the
reasons why the Department of Justice
established our office that is also a
reason we investigated efforts to
obstruct the investigation the matters
we investigated were of paramount
importance it was critical for us to
obtain full and accurate information
from every person we questioned when a
subject of an investigation obstructs
that investigation or lies to
investigators it strikes at the core of
their government's effort to find the
truth and hold wrongdoers accountable
let me say a word about the report the
report has two parts addressing the two
main issues we were asked to investigate
the first volume of the report details
numerous efforts emanating from Russia
to influence the election this volume
includes a discussion of the Trump
campaigns response to this activity as
well as our conclusion that there was
insufficient evidence to charge a
broader conspiracy and in the second
volume the report describes the results
and analysis of our obstruction of
justice investigation involving the
president the order appointing me
special counsel authorized us to
investigate actions that could obstruct
the investigation and we conducted that
investigation and we kept the office of
the acting Attorney General apprised of
the progress of our work and as set
forth in the report after that
investigation if we had had confidence
that the president clearly did not
in a crime we would have said so we did
not however make a determination as to
whether the President did commit a crime
the introduction to the volume 2 of our
report explains that decision it
explains that under long-standing
department policy a president president
cannot be charged with a federal crime
while he is in office that is
unconstitutional even if the charge is
kept under seal and hidden from public
view that too is prohibited the special
counsels office is part of the
Department of Justice and by regulation
it was bound by that department policy
charging the president with a crime was
therefore not an option
we could consider the department's
written opinion explaining the policy
makes several important points that
further informed our handling of the
obstruction investigation those points
are summarized in our report and I will
describe two of them for you first the
opinion explicit explicitly permits the
investigation of a sitting president
because it is important to preserve
evidence while memories are fresh and
documents available among other things
that evidence could be used if there
were co-conspirators who could be
charged now and second the opinion says
that the Constitution requires a process
other than the criminal justice system
to formally accuse a sitting president
of wrongdoing and beyond Department
policy we were guided by principles of
fairness it would be unfair to
potentially it would be unfair to
potentially accuse somebody of a crime
when there can be no court resolution of
the actual charge so that was Justice
Department policy those were the
principles under which we operated and
from them we concluded that we would
would not reach a determination one way
or the other about whether the president
committed a crime
that is the offices yeah that is the
opposites final position and we will not
comment on any other conclusions or
hypotheticals about the president we
conducted an independent criminal
investigation and reported the results
to the Attorney General as required by
department regulations the Attorney
General then concluded that it was
appropriate to provide our report to
Congress and to the American people at
one point in time I requested that
certain portions of the report be
released the Attorney General preferred
to make that and prefer to make the
entire report public all at once and we
appreciate that the Attorney General
made the report largely public and I
certainly did not question the Attorney
General's good faith in that decision
now I hope and expect this to be the
only time that I will speak to you in
this manner I am making that decision
myself no one has told me whether I can
or should testify or speak further about
this matter there has been discussion
about an appearance before Congress any
testimony from this office would not go
beyond our report it contains our
findings and analysis and the reasons
for the decisions we made we chose those
words carefully and the work speaks for
itself and the report is my testimony I
would not provide information beyond
that which is already public in any
appearance before Congress in addition
access to our under the underlying work
product is being decided and a process
it doesn't that does not involve our
office so beyond what I've said here
today and what is contained in our
written work I do not believe it is
appropriate for me to speak further
about the investigation or to comment on
the actions of the Justice Department or
Congress and it's for that reason I will
not be taking questions today as well
now before I step away I want to thank
the attorneys and the FBI agents the
analysts
the professional staff who helped us
conduct this investigation in a fair and
independent manner these individuals who
spent nearly two years with the special
counsels office or of the highest
integrity and I will close by
reiterating the central allegation of
our indictments that there were multiple
systemic efforts to interfere in our
election and that allegation deserves
the attention of every American thank
you thank you for being here today Hey
goodness in concluding he says if we had
confidence the President did not commit
a crime we would have said so